CARTER MORGAN: With almost
500 sessions in Next 2019,
it's understandable you
couldn't get to them all.
So if you didn't see
Hanan Youssef delivering
"Choosing the Right GCE Instance
Type for Your Workload,"
then stay tuned because
here's the rewind.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
Working with a cloud provider
to match your unique needs
with their specific
capabilities can be tricky.
It can be almost impossible
to find the right VM
at the right cost with
the right performance
in the right locations,
and that's not even
taking into account that
your needs and budget will
change as your project grows.
There's got to be a
better solution, which
is why GCP, from
day one, focused
on taking a different approach.
See, we believe in simplicity,
flexibility, and efficiency.
It should be simple to decide
what instance types to use
for your workloads.
You should have the
flexibility to scale up or down
or even change your
instances as needed,
and your cloud offering
should be efficient.
You should not be paying for
resources you're not using.
At GCP, we do this by offering
four types of VMs specialized
for your specific workloads.
We've got general purpose,
compute optimized,
memory optimized, and
even preemptible VMs.
So how do you actually pick
the right VM type for you
on Google Cloud?
For 90% of your workloads,
you can find exactly what
you need with just one click.
Yes, one click because,
for most of your needs,
general purpose VMs are the most
flexible and simplest option.
They're great for a
wide range of workloads
like gaming, databases,
web serving, and more.
They let you upgrade for
more speed or storage,
create custom machine
types, and you even
get recommendations that tell
you when you can make changes,
like downsizing to a smaller
VM that will save you money.
It's pretty cool.
But what about applications with
more specialized CPU or storage
needs?
If you need cutting-edge
processing power
for intensive workloads,
that's where compute
optimized VMs come into play.
These offer the highest
performance per core
available on GCP
and are a great fit
for AAA gaming, high-performance
computing, and some types
of scientific modeling because
you get full transparency
to the underlying hardware,
tight consistency,
and predictable
performance, so you
can bet your most intensive
application on these VMs.
So if you're making
the next "Fortnite,"
this might be for you.
Now, what about
memory-intensive applications
that deal with a ton of data?
That's where memory
optimized VMs come into play.
They have a lot of
size, from one terabyte
to approximately 12
terabytes with more coming.
These are a great
fit for things like
high-end or in-memory databases,
real-time and in-memory
analytics.
These use cutting-edge
technology
to make it simple for you
to persist data, scale
up or down your application,
and access data at high speeds.
And that brings us
to the final type
of workload, bursty
jobs where you
need to run thousands
of cores for a very
short time on the cloud.
That's a job for
preemptible VMs,
our affordable, short-lived
VMs that run for up to 24 hours
and could be preempted
at any point in time.
These are great for
fault-tolerant batch
or rendering jobs,
or simulations
where you need compute
resources but you
don't need the application
to run in real time.
What's cool is this
feature is really
just a flag that you can add to
any of the previous VM types.
And once you add this
flag, you automatically
get a fixed 80% discount, so
you get a predictable pricing
model.
To wrap up, if you're looking
for simple, efficient,
and flexible VMs
for your workloads,
whether they're using
a lot of CPU or memory,
whether they're for
batch workloads or even
something in between,
Google Compute Engine
makes it easy to
find the right VM
at the right cost with the right
performance for your needs.
If you'd like to see
Hanan's full talk, which
goes into much more detail
about the technologies that
make each of these
VM types possible,
click on the link in
the description below.
And don't forget, subscribe
to the Cloud YouTube channel
for more Next Rewind content.
I'm Carter Morgan.
Thanks for watching.